hi and welcome back to sarahs music
today we're celebrating the wonderful
music of the classic MGM musicals and a
brilliant debut we have a bit of
Hollywood in Berlin today with the John
Wilson Orchestra John Wilson and his
orchestra specialize in paying tribute
to the music of the golden era of
Hollywood and Broadway many of the songs
from the MGM film musicals have become
iconic in the 1960s the MGM film scores
were destroyed John has dedicated
himself to reconstructing these scores
to recreate the magic of the MGM film
musicals we're ready to give you some
MGM glamour
to get the public to attend a picture
show it's not enough to advertise a
famous star they know if you want
not have glorious Technicolor breath
take these CinemaScope and Stereophonics
today good witness Valentino in the chic
they never would appreciate that a lot
of boys technique if you want to hear
morning how's versa you gotta have
glorious Technicolor breathtaking
cinemas phone
Oh
the John Wilson orchestra has just
arrived here in the Philemon II and
they're setting up they are set up as a
big band surrounded by a classical
symphony orchestra and I can't wait to
hear what it can sound like in here John
welcome to Berlin thank you it's great
honor to be a real debut for your
orchestra to me I can't quite believe it
dream you're playing music to make your
heart soar really it does how did you
start getting interested in this this
genre you know when i was a kid i was
just fascinated with music whether it be
a record of the greek piano concerto a
beethoven symphony or whatever was on TV
and on rainy Saturday afternoons back in
the 70s and the 80s these films were
shown and I wasn't much interested in
the films but I was interested in the
sound of them there was something about
the energy in the in the playing and the
style of that playing which caught my
ear as a 10 11 year old and it's a sound
I've been trying to replicate ever since
how do you go about restoring cuz I
heard a rumor you you need sometimes two
days for two bars you had the piano
scores or did you have fragments there
are piano scores for a lot of the films
sometimes there's nothing at all but the
soundtrack is always the last word
because that represented the final
thoughts on those composers arrangers
sort of ideas about how the piece should
go but you don't have written down you
get from with your ears you listen yeah
and it takes a certain amount of skill
but mainly patients you know you've got
to just keep listening it's like
archaeology I'm trying to take these
mini masterpieces from the nineteen
thirties forties fifties early sixties
and you know lovingly restore them i
mean i don't want to improve on them i
don't want to put myself into them i
want to get them polished and shining
like the jewels that i think they are
some people from the outside might think
this is a lighter music genre but it's
like you guys take it as seriously as
you would a brook no symphony or a
Brahms Symphony course if you take it
seriously the fact that it's light music
that it's easy to assimilate that it
falls into your lap doesn't make it
easier to play in fact I tell you
something it's quite a lot harder to
play than a lot of you know standard
repertoire because the dressing of this
music that the clothing of these tunes
is so important and the arrangers and
the oxygen throughout these arrangements
they were masters so they really pushed
these oxygens to the limit no it is a
jazz band with a few street that's
exactly right um and we've been adding
as the years go on expanding the
repertoire but I'd say this repertoires
the repertoire which suits this
orchestra the most because it gives
everybody a chance to shine great John
thank you so much thank you thanks for
your time and let's get back and get
ready for the concert d thank you
John Wilson asks you all the strings to
play with so much vibrato that he says
that people's family photos should
shuffle off the TV sets and fall down
that's a lot of vibrato is we're
effectively trying to recreate the sound
of the studio orchestras and the studio
which was of the time such as MGM 1200
Fox they had the best musicians they had
some of the greatest syrupy musicians
who traveled to America because of war
because of problems in Europe and this
concentration of talent led to these the
studio orchestras where everyone's
trying to outdo each other it's a
collection of soloists all trying to
outplay each other and that's
effectively what we're trying to
recreate it's high octane it's pure
Technicolor yes surely this is a little
sailor from the end of one of them where
I left it very exposed and even though
you're playing very quietly you have to
be very intense
Mike you have been described as the soul
of the John Wilson orchestra did you
know that no did well the first trumpet
the lead trumpet is so important for the
sound a whole the whole sound of the
band there's this special vibrato that
you use it's very different to classical
trumpet righto I tend to use the
airstream and the tongue position in the
mouth so instead of Australian oh like
that we've got that kind of sound of a
sheet so it's almost like a shake but
the predominant tone is actually the
middle of the note what's the greatest
thing about this sort of music I think
it's the actual arrangements and the way
that it makes everybody play at their
top of their game makes them play out
and everybody bounces off each other you
know you hear somebody playing the
saxophone or the clarinet or the violin
or whatever it is and it makes you you
know I'm gonna have a girl this now I'm
going to make this sound good you know I
think one of the biggest differences
between that style and and perhaps a
normal orchestral and modern orchestral
style is so much of its about what you
do between the notes it's the vibrating
between the notes and if anything
vibrating more and faster between the
notes to get this incredible sense of
line like the singers of that era you
know they sang with very very fast in
terms of about it and they sung into
such you know consistent lines and
that's effectively what we're trying to
do
my high top shoes in my hair on my head
I went to the Jolly our on the trolley
with his light brown derby on his bright
green time he was quite the handsome man
I started again
I
break
come
my heart screams when you smile
is it true you have different drum sets
for each decade yeah that is true
actually that's incredible these drums
cover up to about 1956 and then I've got
another set of drums that are similar to
these but yet that I go to plastic heads
so it's important to me in this context
getting as close to this music as we're
able to through John to make the right
noise so I've got calf heads instead of
plastic the symbols are though these are
new symbols they're designed and
hammered to sound like very
old-fashioned symbols yeah I think it's
important to be authentic and whatever
music your plan what this orchid makes
it resistant icity it's about playing
not in a kind of dry scholarly way you
know if pipes and ensuring but but you
know you bring your own energy to it but
with a great deal of the enthusiasm
leads to study doesn't it so like you
hear something and you're really
inquisitive you're like oh how did he
make that sound and I love the way the
drum is not speeding up and playing
exactly with the Leitrim it player who's
also playing and then you start
realizing the craft of this to do it
properly that's what we're trying to do
here
Hollywood in the phila money I love it
see you next time on Sarah's music but
first a little bit more John Wilson that
you might see you fight like you see on
the speed the swing daddy Swain for the
love of three top great Shakespearean
scene where a ghost and the Prince Pete
and everyone ends in mincemeat know that
I
so John you say it's an honor to play in
the phila money it's an honor for me to
have you to do the horn challenge we
want a real Technicolor Hollywood blast
of that glossiness god
only one